I'm not saying it's just you I'm saying
that both of you should have worked on
it okay let me let me clarify that like
what you're saying about I I won't say
that my sons my son's dad was abusive I
never ever said anything bad about my
son's dad I remember and you see lots of
people oh you're just like your father I
remember being in the supermarket with
my son and he was missing the boat and I
said to him
do you know what you're just like your
mother you're just like your mother I
don't know why I brought you out and
this woman stopped and said oh um if his
mother was here you know you shouldn't
be talking to him like that and he
looked at me and I looked and I started
laughing because I have never ever said
to him you're just like your father and
sometimes people sit there and they
don't realize that
this sign language there's body language
there's feelings children will pick up
these things some people need to be a
part but by what you're saying and how
religious you are and the fact that you
are married and the fact that you both
know that you need to grow and the fact
that you know the child's life wasn't in
danger the way I'm saying is that what
have separate rooms have separate rooms
in the same house and work out your
differences because at least the child
if you are adult enough to come this far
and when you talk about the trauma from
the previous relationship that's why
Oscar has shared treatment for a trauma
rather than pass it on so you're going
to get back together with your husband
you're not going to have this Trauma
from previous relationship and you're
quite vocal and one thing that you said
that I haven't seen you say gonna do is
like come off social media don't be
influenced by it no it sounds like
social media had a big part of it and
the way you thought marriages should be
so now you know marriages are not like
that then no so okay let me just clarify
I think there's a lot of spec
calculations or something so yeah so
when I initially uh
okay so before I got pregnant let's say
oh no actually yeah before I got
pregnant is when we first had
conversations about him feeling like he
settled down a bit too young right now
that gave me red flags in the sense that
I felt like that to me meant he wants to
be out on the streets does that make
sense so when I say I didn't I didn't I
took that trauma in that was the first
initial uh year of meeting him let's say
and all of that it that sort of came in
it's only when I got pregnant
and then
um I said to him like even then I found
it quite hard to swallow assuming that
he might want other women because at
that point even though I came from
polygenous household I couldn't accept
my man being with other women and that's
when I say social media impacted me
where it said it to me especially them
times it was like oh men can't cheat if
men cheat their trash leave them all of
that blah blah right so obviously when I
after my daughter was born
couple of years later it we Revisited it
but it wasn't in the sense that oh I'm
going to be with other women it was more
him expressing that what if he can't
stay faithful to one person for the rest
of his life now to me again I was still
young I was only like 24 25 at that time
for me again it was like what do you
mean that means you're going to cheat
right to tear so it's almost like okay
fine if you're gonna cheat then I don't
want to be with you so we separated
because for me I couldn't swallow the
fact that he might in the future want to
be so cool so you left I thought you
said no so well the relationship up to
the point where we were arguing or I was
being toxic or unhappy so he was like I
can't do this right so obviously we
separated after we separated cool we've
done our we've gone our separate way
again when I say finding myself I'm not
talking about exploring other people or
bodies I'm talking about revisiting what
who I am and my course well and I
understand that but like when you you
were talking talking about earlier
because a lot of the things we're saying
we're just saying what you said back to
you so like earlier you said you did the
dating apps you you were going on dates
you went to Carnival and like that that
sounds like and I think that's where
again a lot of my like the society will
impact you because again people in my
ear oh you're young you're this girl why
not date I had to then ask myself I've
got a child I could date another guy is
he going to treat my child the same as
her dad is he gonna love me is he not
going to cheat on me and then I have to
say actually I can't guarantee that so
that's why I haven't dated or moved on
thank you
so like you so how old your child five
six no six so you're you're not going to
be with a dad you think okay I'm gonna
start dating another guy you would at
least wait you know a good year before
you know they're really in the child's
life I have two children
um and obviously I'm not not with the
dad and whatever
um and I've had like I made the updated
one guy since didn't meet my kids didn't
speak to my kids like he knew their
names that was it because I'm not going
to fetch a guy into their life just to
be temporary so I think when when you
speak like that you you do need to know
that they're going to be there but even
that so for me I again I date with
intention but even that deal with
intention is still very different in my
culture because in my culture we get
married very quick to meeting people
like I'm not in that culture but I I do
I date to marry that's what I personally
would like to do
um you know I wouldn't have chosen to
have kids this young if I'd planned it
and obviously I don't regret them but I
would still try to be as traditional as
I could
um but I think it is it's harder in this
generation and you've just got to be a
lot more careful
I had my son at 17. that made me grow up
yes it wasn't it wasn't that I was gonna
say oh I was too young you know
[ __ ] happens you do with it just get on
with it right and not once it I think to
myself yeah I'm a single parent I'm
gonna start dating didn't think about
that at all it was just concentrate on
my child I didn't even think consider
dating at all but that's what I'm saying
that's what I did yeah that's what I'm
doing yeah like I'm not considering
dating that I said I'm not even mingling
with people I'm not intending if if I
met someone and I thought organically
and I thought oh my God they blow my
mind that's one thing you're not looking
forward well it's just okay when you say
that and then earlier you said you were
on dating apps it kind of like it was
just the initial breakup obviously when
you're in your feelings and you're
broken up and my friends are like oh
you're single because I haven't ever
been single yeah it was the first time
I'm single and women our age were all
dating at that time 25 26. they were all
trying to date not even with you there's
a lot of single mums trying to do it in
in our with my modern women but again
that's again what I had to revisit I had
to say to myself am I going to find a
man who's not going to treat me yeah but
you see like how it sounds when you say
it like your story like keeps
contradicting itself like it like I
haven't even really asked you like like
you've been going on like talking about
it and like volunteering this
information and then like you keep
contradicting yourself and I think the
reason is is because I am a clash of
cultures so I am very you know obviously
I'm Bangladeshi British Muslim and I
think the modern side is what is me what
I'm fighting against does that make
sense so the more I'm realizing actually
I'm not this model woman is the more
comfortable I'm getting in who I am I
don't I don't think you can really go
back like I I don't think you can really
claim traditional if you're separated
from your like your husband it's no when
I say traditional I say traditionally my
values in my models not that I'm I'm I'm
gonna stick in a marriage that I'm
unhappy in because I'm a traditional
woman it's more I know what I want for
myself and I know that this right but
like that rhetoric right there that
sounds very modern what can I just say
again all I'm hearing is I I I I I I I'm
not and I'm not trying to personalize it
to you it's just that you're speaking
and a lot of the things that have been
said today are eye base and in
relationships in marriage it's about
partnership working together and we're
not nobody's perfect sometimes sometimes
you make mistakes and you have to work
through it and we've I'm not married
I've never been married and I think it's
easy for me to talk on it you know from
my perspective but when you've got a
child involved your feelings involved
you know finances involved whatever it
might be work involved your friends
involved
you you have to kind of peel back on all
of the factors that influence you and
look at the bare bones of the
relationship which is you your child and
your partner and literally Zone in on
that and make that your priority wait
I've got a question I've got a question
quickly just to kind of caveat off it
yeah yeah so on that note because you're
talking about I I do would you say that
the Modern Woman is selfish then yes
because it because society allows that
to be the case because it's about what
you want or is it what the woman that's
the case
because I've been very selfless in
relationships I've got nothing back
right exactly yeah but so but if you
love yourself no no no but it's very
involved you kind of have to be selfish
I started to cut you off yeah that's all
right selfish like how though
when young kids involved well like your
kids are your priorities so it's like
regardless of what how anybody feels
like your child is your priority isn't
apparent to stay in that relationship
with two parents my priority is to take
care of my child yeah yeah that's but
that's that's being selfless like when
you have a kid it's not supposed to be
about you anymore it's about your kid
[ __ ] your happiness but that's exactly
unless you're in like extenuating
circumstances where you are getting
abused or yeah I'm with you I'm with you
if you're a child if your child's in
danger yeah I I agree but that's not
that's not the majority of cases it's
the child's name danger you need to try
work out too but that's exactly what
like for example my daughter doesn't
know we're separate my daughter hasn't
experienced anything different when she
sees us she sees us very amicable and
she she doesn't know anything different
so when I say something else no we don't
live in the same house okay but when I
say that when I say I'm putting my
daughter first that's the reason why I'm
not chasing another man or chasing
another relationship because the most
beneficial one is me and her father
right like see you keep kind of
contradicting yourself and you did it
again just here there because you said
your daughter you don't live in the same
house but your daughter doesn't know
anything's up she may not at five but
she will yeah and when and so and so she
might not understand it but you you
can't say that it's like she's not gonna
notice that her dad or her mom isn't in
the home